why do I have black against the sky all
the time and by the way welcome to this
video it's hagen and he will play b 3 as
in every game yes I don't really get it
and I have black against him I mean
every game really it's quite uncanny
I've got 20 out of 25 against him no
draws in five losses 20 wins what's he
doing looking up his book moves he
should know about b3 is doing this in
every game really every game ok maybe I
can try something else maybe go for a
fee and shadow so what is this chair
something like this that's not very
exciting but you can't have exciting
positions in all games interesting is he
trying to maybe castles Bishop e3 yet
could be could be tricky check
interesting Bishop a 3m could be could
be a problem is going for this maybe
night 26 interesting
it's not bad at all so this is a line
that I should quickly discard for
further for future use it's just better
for wide f6 it's not very attractive but
maybe forgetting night f7 I'm shoring up
my defenses you can go MIA he has those
moves there okay night f7 Bishop c4 LA
okay even Bishop e7 as a move sometimes
wow that is not good
you
remarkable how how problematic this
position is
two nite nite g 80s route de de de okay
and 97 he will check me on this sex
which looks kind of awkward but not sure
if it is how bad it is he can take on d7
an ID f6 check I sorry I can take with
the bishop on yourself but what an ugly
position I need like one or two moves to
consolidate but I really don't know if I
ever get this time I really don't know
bra much not possible not possible I
don't have many moves here 96 is really
really awkward
bishop f3 always has this Bishop e6
centium night f5 again there is bishop
e6
and maybe I can go back then to age 6 no
one take the seven blah Wow amazing it's
an amazingly bad position maybe this 196
King see 7 95 95 is ugly but might might
be might be holding check
you
oh yeah yeah yeah yeahs can play um can
play them can play em marriage form here
will take
it's got night h4 that's the problem
takes takes Knight edge for and their
five drops okay almost i have f4 which
is also damn ugly
you can take f4 LMP should be six okay
maybe each x f4 i can i can insert the
song okay may-maybe maybe this is
somehow still possible to fry it didn't
see that one coming but okay I can maybe
do this if you take fa drew kf8 yeah f45
FF 65 I'm x-raying on f 2 so this is
some not totally easy to win maybe
g-form
I have to shoot for some kind of
activity in this position cake stinks
time warning I g4 maybe check that that
game really was no fun
Jeff
King you too is just good just simple
just simple moves check okay I didn't
even see that is heaven was hanging
didn't even see that
yeah just read this check him chair
black resigns Wow there was that ball
that was a really bad position on in the
opening I mean I thought that okay it's
probably not brilliant here but it's
really bad this is really bad amazing
check amazing how bad this is then it's
it is absolutely absolutely awful to
play I mean okay Bishop f8 is a good
move that I missed here to defend better
word wow this is just totally totally
rotten and white has many many possible
ways to keep the pressure on oh yeah I
could have played b5 I didn't consider
that one it was pretty decent actually
okay check yeah and here the problem
really was exactly what he did this is
picking up picking up material Jim maybe
I didn't defend it who defend it very
tenacious Lee but what a rotten position
Wow ok this is to be avoided this do you
take c5 stuff well okay well thanks for
watching